Efendim selamlar
aşağı yukarı 40 yıl Ankara'da yaşadım
İzmir kökenliyim ben de
Türk Koleji mezunuyum ağırlıklı fen
okudum
Ama okul tiyatro kolunda sürekli
faaliyet haldeydim
biraz
çelişki gibi yani Hem ağırlıklı fen
okuyup hem de tiyatro kolunda olmak okul
bandosunda tenör saksafon çalıyordum
sportif faaliyetler yapıyordum
babam İzmir ağır ceza reisiydi Zeki
Levent Annem
Olgunlaşma Enstitüsü
profesyonel
Son derece güzel moda dizaynları
çiziyordu ve onları işte dostu istediği
zaman veriyordu onlar yaptırıyorlardı
onları falan o bakımdan çok titizdi hani
çizgileri muhteşemdi
liseler çok hoştu
Dolayısıyla ben
bu ikilinin çocuğu olarak yaşarken çok
şey öğrendim onlardan
mesela bunların hepsini daha sonra fark
ediyor babam o zaman fark etmemiştim
Mesela bir gün
eve misafirler gelmişti
konuşuluyor
bir hanım bir şey söylüyor başka hanım
onun sözünü kesiyor ve kendi kafasına
göre ona cevap veriyor Öbürü de o konuyu
bırakıyor onu söylediğine devam ediyor
sonra o bunu da bırakıyor filan bir
müddesü ver konuşmalarını takip edemez
oldum Onları Çünkü ikisi de birbirini
dinlemiyorlardı
fakat bir konuşuyorlar gibi de bir hava
var
en sonunda bir bakmışım ki akşam benimle
Annem ve babam biraz gırgır geçtiler yap
aramızda Çünkü ben ona diyormuşum O
senin dediğini demiyor diyormuş ona da
diyorum sen onu yanlış anlıyorsun
diyormuş bu sıralarda da 3-4 yaşındaymış
[Müzik]
Bir de biraz daha yaşım ilerlediğinde
yani 6-7 yaşıma geliyor çok Soru sormaya
başlamışım
Ben böyle bu kadar soru sordukça Onlar
da bana cevap yetiştirmeye çalışırlar ve
yorulurlarmış fakat bir gün babamın
gülerek bana ukala dediğini hatırlıyorum
ukala
yani olumsuz bir şey söylemedim ama daha
sonra bunu bu hikayemi bildiğim için
başkalarınız çocuklar böyle soru sorduğu
zaman konuşma başımıza iş açma Nereden
çıktı şimdi bu sorular diye cevap
verdiklerinde gördüm belki sizler de
görmüşsünüzdür
Halbuki çocukların o çağda sorduğu
soruların Ben son derece saf temiz Hatta
hepimize
sorulabilecek ve hepimizin cevap araması
gereken sorular olduğunu düşünür Eğer
çocuklar o sorular sorulduğu zaman
onlara çok ciddi aydınlatıcı cevaplar
verilirse Hatta cevabını bilmiyorsanız
bunu Gel birlikte araştıralım derseniz o
çocuğun kişisel gelişiminde son derece
önemli etkili bir rol oynamış olursunuz
diye düşünüyor aksi çocuğu
sıradanlaştırıyor
ben bunları anlamaya başladığım zamanlar
bir farkındalığın farkındalığı olduğunu
anlamaya başladım kendimde
böyle kakafonik bir laf gibi değil mi
farkındalığın farkındalığı Çünkü Kendi
farkındalığımı fark etmeye başladım
Kendi farkındalığımı fark etmeye
Başladığım zaman bunu arkadaşlarımla da
paylaşmak istiyordum fakat arkadaşlarım
benim söylediğim şeyleri saçma
buluyorlardı
Çünkü fark ettiğim şeylerin önemli
olduğu Ben kendime göre düşünürken onlar
bunu pek düşünmüyorlar
Ben de onlarla Bunu onlara bunu sürekli
anlatmaya çalışıyor
İşte o gün bugündür bunu yapmaya
çalışıyorum anlatmaya çalışıyorum
bizim çocukluğumuzda
yani
1950'li 55'li yıllardan bahsediyorum
biraz kahramanlık hakimdi
bir araya geldiğimizde bizim bir ev
vardı evin karşısında bir ara tarla
tarla diyorduk o zaman ona o tarlada 5-6
tane incir ağacı Bir tane iki tane hurma
ağacı vardı şimdi o tarla yok orası
apartman Adası oldu
Biz o tarlada oyun oynuyor
sonra bir gün geldi temel kazmaya
başladılar o temellerin içerisinde dek
bana oynamaya başladık vurdum seni falan
diye
bütün bunları yaparken yine çocukça
şeyler konuşup kendi aramızda hayatın
daha iyi olması konusunda neler
yapabiliriz neredeyse tartışıyorduk
işte Mahalle arası futbol maçları
yapıyorduk futbol maçlarında haksızlık
olduğu zaman kabul ediyorduk kabul
etmeyen olursa kavga çıkıyordu
kavga etmek çok normaldi Yani
yurtseverlik kavga etmek gibi bir şeydi
yani o gün Savaş çıksa o küçücük
halimizle biz hemen savaşa gitmeye hazır
gibiydi Sanki yurtseverliği de bundan
ibaret bir şey zannediyorduk
sonra yıllar geçti işte
okul kolejde
birçok şeyler evrildi hayatımda
tiyatronun bana çok etkisi oldu fakat
tiyatrocu olmamı aklımdan geçirmiyordum
açıkçası Çünkü babam ağır ceza Emekli
olduktan sonra avukatlık bürosu açmıştı
ve İzmir'in pek çok avukatı onun yanında
Stajyerlik yapıyordu
Annem de biraz böyle Saraylar falan
ilişkisi vardı o da ailede onun ailesine
çok
büyükelçi vardı babam
hukuk oku gel işte büron hazır diyordu
Annem de hariciyeci ol diyordu seni
büyükelçi olarak görmek istiyorum
diyordu O zamanki büyükelçi imajı çok
havalıydı
ben de işte
üniversite seçme sınavlarında İzmir
İktisat Fakültesi'nde kazandım
Erzurum'da İngiliz Dili ve edebiyatını
kazandım Ankara'da da siyasal bilgileri
kazandım
İzmir İktisat fakültesine girmek kolay
geliyordu Ama o zamanlar İktisat okumak
çok makbul değildi sanki Çünkü aileden
birileri bana İktisat Okuyup ne
yapacaksın bankada memur mu olacaksın
falan demişlerdi
bankada memur olma bak gibi bir şey
durum vardı yani
ama askerlik geliyordu bu sefer gittim
Erzurum'a ön kayıt yaptırdım Sonra bir
baktım Ankara'da da siyasalda ön kayıt
hakkım doğdu oraya geldim ve o zaman
yanımda olan iki üç arkadaş benim
kolejde tiyatro oynadım tiyatro kolunda
da olduğunu bildikleri için Gel bak
burada konservatuar var Orada da tiyatro
bölümü varmış dediler
şimdi Tiyatro bölümleri çok arttı ama
tiyatro bölümlerinde
bölümlerin olduğunu bile neredeyse
bilmiyor gibiydik Ben de gittim Ankara
Devlet konser otu arkadaşlarla birlikte
gittik
işte Kapıda bir arkadaş oturuyor ona
dedim burada tiyatro bölümü var mı var
dedi
nasıl müracaat edebilirim dedim işte
baktı senin yaşın kaç dedi Söyledim
Doğum tarihimi senin dedi 6 ay geçmiş
seni almazlar
işte nasıl olur filan diye konuşunca
dedi ki bir de bir şans var dedi
seviye sınavına girersen dedi Kazanırsan
Bakanlar Kurulu kararıyla Konservatuarı
alınabilirsin dedi Ben de girmiyorum o
zaman dedim çıkıyordum arkadaşlar gir
falan diye benim de biraz arkadaş
iteklemesi yaptılar
ve doldurdum formu girdim
konservatuar tiyatro bölümü sınavına ve
pek de Heyecanlı bir dönem bu kadar
ayrıntıya girmeyeceğim kazandım
kazanınca da
siyasala ön kaydımı yaptırmış gibi
diplomamı
fotokopisini bırakmıştım Erzurum'a orada
almam gerekiyordu
Efendim konservatulara girdikten sonra
ben sanki annemlere Neden tiyatrocu
olmak istediğimi anlatmam lazım gibi bir
şeye Kapıldım ve bu nedenle Tiyatro
nedir Ne işe yarar diye araştırmalar
yapmaya başladım
o sırada herkes sanat diyordu buna sanat
Hatta İsrail 5 yıl okuduk Biz
konservatuarda ishali 1 sınıf
şubatta ve Haziranda eleme vardı yani
başarısız olursanız okuldan
ayrılıyordunuz O zamanki hocamız Mahir
canova daha sınıfa girdiğimizde
isimlerimizi yazdık önümüze koyduk
herkese soruyordu Neden tiyatrocu olmak
istiyorsunuz diye
arkadaşlar böyle biraz daha havalı bir
durum olsun diye meşhur olmak için
sahneye çıkmak için falan dediler
ben hiç aklımdan bu geçmiyordu Ben
insanı tanımak için dedim
yani insanı tanımak için tiyatrocu olmak
istiyordum Hala da insanı tanımak için
yapıyorum bu işi
ama bunu söyledikten sonra herkes sanat
diyor ve sanat dedikçe de akıllarına
Tiyatroları isim ve iken müzik Mimarlık
falan geliyor ben bu lafı ettim Sanat ne
demek
ve Sanat ne demek onu araştırmanın
peşine düştüm
Tabi bizde sanat deyince insanın aklına
resim heykel tiyatro müzik Mimarlık
falan gelince biz sanatın ayrı bir mana
ifade ettiğini o zaman Tahmin etmiyorduk
ben de bilmiyordum
bunu bilmediğim zaman yani aklım resim
heykel tiyatro müziği sanat olarak kabul
ettiği zaman
sanatı anlatan kitaplar okuduğunda da
hiçbir şey anlamıyordum
Çünkü sanatı anlatan kitapları yazan
kişiler sanatın bir süreç olduğunu
anlatıyorlardı
yani sadece resim heykel tiyatro müzik
Mimarlık değil
yaşamın her alanında yapılan işin
titizlikle özenle disiplinle
çalışkanlıkla gerçekleştirilmesine sanat
diyorlardı
ama biz bunu anlamıyorduk Çünkü sanat
resim heykel tiyatro müzik mimarlıktan
ibaretti
Fakat bunlar Tabii dönüyor dönüyor
kafamda tekrar anlama
isteği yaratıyordu
ve de etrafımızda tanıdık insanlar Yurt
dışına gidip gelenler oradaki
kültürlerden bahsedenler vardı ve
kavramların giderek yavaş yavaş son
sınıflara doğru kavramların farklı
kullanıldığını fark etmeye başladım
dedim ya bir farkındalığı fark etme
eğilimi vardı üzerimde
o zaman kavramların doğru anlamlarını
tekrar araştırmaya yöneldim ara
vermiştim
bu sefer aradan sonra anlamaya başladım
Sanat hangi işi yaparsanız yapın onu
özenle yapmak demek
yani
İlla resim heykel tiyatro müzik Mimarlık
değil yani resim heykel müzik Mimarlık
yapan insan bu işi kötüsünü de yapamaz
mı
yani
konservatuarda okurken öğrenciyken ne
olacaksın diye sorduklarında bize oyuncu
olacağız diyordu ama mezun olur olmaz
Herkes sanatçı olur
iş bulsa da bulmasa da sanatçı ne iş Ne
iş yapıyorsun diye soruluyor mezun
olmadan önce Oyuncu olacağım diye yani
arkadaş mezun olduktan sonra sanatçıyım
demeye başladı
sanatçıyım diye bir meslek olabilir mi
arkadaşlar
sanatçı diye bir meslek yok
sanatçı uzun bir yolda yürüyen hayatı
keşfetmeye çalışan farkındalıkları fark
eden
farkındalıklar üzerinden kendini
geliştiren ve bu gelişmesini de
başkalarıyla paylaşmak isteyen
insanlardır
Sağ olun
tabii
mesela o zamanlar Aristo okuyorum
poin okuyorum Aristo bir işi özenle
yapmanın İyi güzel ve doğru ölçüsü
ölçüsünden geçeceğini söylüyor bir kişi
İyi güzel ve doğru yapmayı tek tek
mesela İyiyi aşağı yukarı 500 ile
inceliyor
paragrafta inceliyor doğruyu da
neredeyse bin para bu kadar mı
karışıkmış bu İyi güzel Doğru evet
Sokrat Herkes o da çok biliyorsunuz
artık sokratı anlatmayacağım Biraz önce
de konuşuldu fakat
günümüze geldikçe estetik değerlerin
yaratılmasına baktığınızda estetik
kavramı bizde
botoks yaptırmak olarak anlaşılıyor
değil mi onun dışında bir faydası yokmuş
gibi estetik kavramının Halbuki estetik
yaşamın bütününü kapsıyor
yani Evet bunu anlamadım Kabul etmenize
çok sevindim
geçenlerde bir Boğaziçi Zirvesi
toplantısı yapılacak İstanbul onu
toplantısındaydım birçok akademisyen
arkadaşımız vardı Hepsi de çok değerli
kim ekonomide şu yapmalı Bilmem
Siyasette bu olmadı şunu da şu olmadı
Bunu da bu olmadı derken bana sen ne
diyorsun dedim ki bu Konuştuklarınızın
hepsi daha önce yurt dışında da tuz for
analizi diye analiz için anahtarlar diye
bir konferans var demiştim dedim ki bu
konuştuklarınız iğne iplik kumaş düğüme
bunları ama hepsi insan için insan
nerede biz bunları hep teknik düzeyde
konuşuyoruz ama estetik düzeyde
konuştuğumuz zaman insanı katmış
oluyoruz bu işin içerisine estetik
botoks değil estetik yaşamın
güzelleştirilmesi yaşamdan haz alınması
ve de ayrıntılı düşünme biçimi demek
sanat ayrıntılı düşünme biçimi demek
çarçabuk birilerini suçlamak doğru bir
şey değil çünkü onun ne düşündüğünü
Neden böyle hareket ettiğini hayatında
hangi şansları ve şansızlıkları olduğunu
bizim düşünebilmemiz gerekir empati
dediğimiz kavram sanatın başlangıcıdır
Eğer empati kurmuyorsak sanat da
yapamayız kendimizi ifade edemeyiz
mesela
sanatın ifade olduğunu biz
hakasya'ya gitmiştim
170 ülkede drama çalışmaları yaptım
drama dediğimiz zaman Türkiye'de de o
zamanlar acıklı diye anlaşılıyordur ama
acıklı şimdi drama kelimesini acıklı
olarak anladığımız zaman bu kelimeden
hiç yararlanamıyoruz biz
Çünkü drama demek bir konuyu her insanın
kendi iç aksiyonu ve dış aksiyonuyla rol
oynama metoduyla anlatması ve de
incelemesi demek
O halde bir durumu Biz dram demek durum
demek yani bir durumu Biz defalarca rol
oynama metodu ile canlandırabiliriz
Doğaçlama olarak ve de hangisi doğruyu
Aristo'nun dediği İyi güzel doğruya
hangisi yaklaşıyor tartışabiliriz Bu
tartışmayı yaptığımız zaman zihin
hareketlerimiz çalışmaya başlıyor zihin
hareketlerimiz çalışmaya başladığı zaman
kendimizi ifade edecek sözcükleri
bulmamız gelişmeye başlıyor O zaman
ifade sanatı ortaya çıkıyor ama ifade
edebilmek için düşünme sanatını
geliştirmemiz lazım şimdi pek çok insan
sanat kavramında
esasında sana süreç ve sürecin ürüne
dönüşmesi demek yani düşüncenin önüne
dönüşmesi
resimden örnek vereceğim İlla sanat
olarak gördüğümden değil sana Resimde
bir zanaat çünkü Ama mesela Leonardo Da
Vinci'nin
bir tablosunu İsa'nın son akşam yemeğini
yada Mona Lisa
bir replikacı bir tablo tamircisi bir
günde yapabiliyor Biliyor musunuz Bir
günde
Peki bu adam niye Leonardo Da Vinci
olmuyor
neden
Çünkü o tabloyu düşünen kişi değil o
Demek ki sanatın özü düşünce
önce düşünmek sonra ifade etmek
gerekiyor da Vinci'nin Da Vinci hiç
kuşkusuz sanatçı diyebiliriz çünkü
kimyada matematikte pek çok bilimde
uzman bir kişi aynı konuşuyorsunuz
Dolayısıyla
bizim
Da Vinci'nin İsa'nın son akşam yemeğini
ya da Mona Lisa yapması Da Vinci'nin
kendi düşüncesini ifade etmek için mi
bir süreç ve ortaya çıkan tablo ürün
benim sanat konusunda şu konuşmayı
yapmam o da bir konuşmada bir ürün
ve doktor Berna kalp nakli yapması bir
süreç
nakli yapması kendini ifade etmesi
bakın böyle bakmıyordum ben hiç olayı
ama hiç sonra anlamaya başladım
ama başka bir kitabı var ondan önce
yazdığı insanlığın kısa tarihi diye
gomrić mağara devrinde aleti ilk bulan
insandan günümüze olan gelişkin tümünü
sanat olarak değerlendiriyor
ve bu içmeyi sağlayan insanın bugünkü
insanı yarattığını söylüyor
Ama bu insanların hep birbirleriyle
çelişkileri söz konusu Çünkü Aristo'nun
dediği İyi güzel doğrunun karşıtı var
Kötü Çirkin ve yanlış Kötü Çirkin ve
yanlış hiçbir zaman eksik olmuyor kötü
çirkin ve yanlışı bize gösteren
davranışlar esasında İyi güzel ve
doğrunun nimetlerini kullanıyorlar Ama
bu nimetleri kullanırken Kötü Çirkin ve
yanlış davranışlarda bulunuyorlar O
halde bizim bunu muhakeme edip bu
muhakeme sonucunda Bunu ifade edebilir
bir hale gelmemiz lazım ki bu sana ve de
çözüm önermemiz lazım
çözümsüz bir Tartışmanın bence hiçbir
değeri yok çünkü çözüm Önermek üzere bir
sürece girip o sürecin sonunda da çözümü
ürün olarak ortaya koymamız lazım süreç
ürünü yaratıyorsa
o üründe yeni süreci yaratıyor yeni
süreç yeni ürünü yeni ürün yeni süreci
ta oradan bugüne geliyoruz şimdi
diyebilir miyiz ki biz
Bizim bugün doğan çocuğumuz mağara
devrinde Doğan çocukla aynı
genolojik olarak bir kere değişme var
değil mi bu süreç içerisinde
bugün doğan çocuk daha doğduğu andan
itibaren farklı bir davranış içerisinde
bulunuyor
şimdi o zaman insanı kendisini
güncellemesi gerekiyor
sanat kavramı insanı kendisini
güncellemesi konusunda da ona dürtüde
bulunuyor uyarıda bulunuyor Bu
güncelleme Çağın gelişmeleri yaşadığımız
ortam insan psikolojisini anlamak çözüm
üretmek bu anlam anlam yükledikten sonra
anlamı da tekrar ifade etmeye dönmeye
gerektiriyor
Bu şartlarda
Ben artık Picasso'nun şöyle bir lafı var
diyor ki bütün insanlar sanatçıdır
ama
bunu doğduktan sonraki dönemlerinde
Sürdürülebilir hale getirmek gerekir
diyor yani şu anlama geliyor insanların
sanatçı olarak doğduklarını kabul edip
Onlara fırsat vermek gerekiyor ama bu
fırsatı veremediğimiz zaman o fırsatı
elde edebilenler olabiliyor O elde
edebilenlerin de ben neyin farkına
vardım nasıl farkına vardımsa
başkalarına da bunu anlatmam ifade etmem
ve de yaşamalarını sağlayacak imkanlar
yaratmam lazım diye bir sorumluluk
göstermesi gerekiyor diye düşünüyorum
Bertuğ Break diye ünlü tiyatro adamı da
sanatların En yücesi yaşama sanatıdır
diyor
O halde Ben salona şimdi Diyorum
hepimizin sanatçı olduğunu ve bunun
farkındalığını elde etmemiz gerektiğini
hatırlayarak sanata evet der miyiz
sayıyorum Bir iki üç dediğim zaman 3
defa aynı anda güçlü bir şekilde ve de
tek ses gibi diyebilir miyiz
1 2 3
[Alkış]
olmadı olmadı bakın alsan bul olmadı
alsan bul olsun alsan bul ne demek aynı
anda söylemek demek Hazır mıyız
sayıyorum 1 2 3
[Alkış]
bravo bravo
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]